[applause]
>>Dan Schawbel: Thanks so much for having
me. We're gonna talk about my story first
and then I'm gonna give you some high level
information on personal branding and then
I'm gonna walk you through the four step personal
branding process that's in Me 2.0, the book
all of you have in front of you.
So when I got started, when I got started
I had eight internships in seven years for
positions in college. I was trying to figure
out everything on my own so I started from
really nothing and I had to get each internship
in order to build my profile to get the next
internship. I went to these internships with
what I call now a personal branding toolkit,
different materials that help you sell me
as a person, now as a brand; so business card,
a website, a CD portfolio of work, like all
these materials and they would help me stand
out during these interviews.
The problem that I had was I never networked
and I was a little bit afraid to network and
as a result it took me eight months, meeting
15 people, getting rejected twice to get my
first job out of school, so it was a hard
lesson learned.
But one of the most fascinating things that
happened before I got my job at EMC was during
one of the last interviews they looked at
my resume, which was two pages, and they said,
"Wow you worked at Reebok." Now when I had
my internship at Reebok I did almost nothing,
I hate to admit to people watching [laughs]
that work at Reebok. But I had so much experience
at the smaller firms, but they cared about
Reebok because Reebok was a brand and the
brand opened the door, I got the job.
And then about a year later I read Tom Peters'
"A Brand Called You" article which was written
back in 1997 on the cover of Fast Company
magazine. And when I read this article it
called out to me. He was saying you have to
be the chief marketing officer for the brand
called you. You have to be the CEO of Me,
Inc.
And reading his article I was saying "Wow,
this is exactly what I've been doing all along,
marketing myself" without even knowing of
that term. And so I started the personal branding
blog which is now personalbranding.com that
used to be personalbranding.wordpress.com
when it was first started. And when I started
this I started writing 10 to 12 posts a week
because I love to do it, I knew that I could
probably become the spokesperson of my generation;
I'm 27, I was 23 years old then. So I just
started writing and just getting my ideas
out and everything that I'd learned along
the way: getting the internships, getting
the jobs throughout college to help other
individuals who were struggling.
And then, what I did was, I started a few
more projects. I'll go through a few of these.
The Personal Brand Awards and we wanted to
recognize people who are already really successful
building brands online. And I also did Personal
Branding TV which was very uncomfortable for
me. I still don't really like doing video,
but I put videos of myself interviewing CEO's
and executives so you get to meet my own uncle.
And I also gave like chalkboard lectures and
tried to get my ideas out in a different format
because I believe that you pretty much have
to put everything in any format that your
audience is looking for right now.
And then what I did was I wrote articles.
Now I had never written articles before, I
didn't consider myself a writer, I didn't
think I was that great of a writer during
high school or college. And I got the opportunity
to write for about.com which was my first
opportunity to write. And it was published
and when it was published I said, "Wow, this
is incredible! Someone's willing to publish
something that I wrote."
I took that published work, and anytime you
get published you get a lot of benefits. It
positions you as an expert, you get links
back to your site, increases your Google standing,
and builds traffic to your site. So it's really
good, it really helps you. And I took that
published article and I used it to get my
next opportunity.
So my next opportunity was with American Marketing
Association. I wrote a best practice on personal
branding for them used both of those published
works to get my next opportunity. It took
me six months but I got published in Branding
Magazine which was a pretty big deal at the
time for me.
And then I just kept building and building
and while I was building that I was still
blogging, I was commenting on any single blog
that mentioned personal branding. It's a ton
of work, so you have 40 to 50 hours a week
at my day job at EMC Corporation in product
marketing, and then I'd go home, I'd sacrifice
nights, I sacrificed weekends to continue
to build upon something that I truly believed
in, not getting any money to do any of this.
And then I started Personal Branding Magazine
because I wanted to continue to position myself
as an expert 'cause I call myself a personal
branding spokesperson for Gen Y, I didn't
want to just take the expert status right
away I wanted to feel like I proved myself
and I was worthy of the expert status.
So the first issue had 11 articles and the
cover was Donald Trump, an interview between
him and Guy Kawasaki. And on that day when
it launched I was also profiled in Fast Company
which was 10 years to the day Tom Peters'
article came out, but more positioning me
as the person who understood personal branding
for the younger generation tied with this
new social media technology which was really
heating up at this point; Facebook has like
700 million users now. So at that point it
was starting to go a little bit more mainstream
back in 2007.
And when it launched I never told my employer
what I was doing outside of work, it was just
a hobby, I wasn't making money, I wasn't,
I didn't see it as a big deal. PR got wind
of it because it noted that I was working
at EMC in a private marketing role at this
point while doing everything else. PR sent
it to a vice president, the vice president
called me into his office which was a big
deal I was an entry level candidate which
was very intimidating. And then he introduced
me to the head of public relations, the head
of public relations called me in.
And it took me so much work, over such a long
period of time to get into this company and
now they're coming to me based on my online
personal branding, something I had built based
on my passion. To me that was profound and
I was ready to really market myself to this
head of PR. I brought him a press kit, I brought
him a printed copy of the Brandweek Magazine
article. I was doing whatever I could, but
I was already sold through that third party
endorsement based on everything I was doing
outside of work.
And so I was able to co-create the first social
media position back in November 2007 which
inspired me to write Me 2.0, now you have
the second edition now, but back then I got
my own book deal. I got rejected by 70 agents,
let's me see, I got rejected by 70 agents
and two publishers, kept with it in January
2008 I got the book deal.
And then after speaking at more companies
and continually building upon what I had already
been doing and building more business model
around that with consulting, speaking, and
the advertising platform that I've created,
I started Millennial Branding, LLC, and that's
my company now.
[pause]
What are these two toddlers talking about?
They're talking about their online brand because
92% of them already have one. And why I bring
this up is it's not really the content that
they're creating about themselves even though
80% of them use the Internet, they're just
not that savvy at this point. It's what other
people are creating about them and that's
why you need to own your brand because if
you don't take a stand, if you don't publish
content based on your passion, what you wanna
become an expert in and really get yourself
out there, other people will have control
over your career future.
[pause]
I look at the Internet different than most
people. I look at it as the global talent
pool; this is where all the recruitings occur;
this is where all the opportunities are. And
for that reason you need to build an online
presence; you need your own website, at your
full name dot com, you need to be on social
networks because people need to find you.
Because if people are searching for you or
people like you, you have to come up or you're
gonna lose an opportunity every single time
they perform that Google search.
And more and more employers are saying, "Forget
about the resume, we are just gonna search
for you online and whatever comes up that's
gonna depict whether you get the job or not.
As you can see 34% of companies feel that
the online presence is really taking over
the resume, and this trend is just continuing.
[pause]
There's three skills you need or three main
big ideas. Is that the first one is you need
hard skills. And back in the day, if you had
the right hard skills, if you got the degree,
if you were a good software programmer, you'd
be pretty much guaranteed the job. And then
it became more competitive to get jobs so
now not only do you have to be able to program,
let's say, but you need good communication
skills. You need to be well organized, you
have to be able to talk with people, you have
to be able, you have to be a good writer,
you have to fit in the corporate culture,
all these things leadership, all these things
became more and more important.
And now were entering another stage where
not only do you have to have great hard skills
and soft skills, but you have to have online
influence. And we're gonna talk about more
about that towards the end of the presentation.
You have to be able to establish a strong
network, you have to be able to have to have
people listen to what you have to say, and
maybe retweet you and spread your messages.
And that's gonna account for more and more
in the future.
And you don't wanna end up like the dinosaurs.
And I think the biggest challenge for people
now and in the future is to stay relevant.
It's becoming so hard, I mean, I read and
scan 800 RSS feeds a day in order to keep
up. I mean it's my business to keep up, but
in a sense if you don't know what's going
on with your company and industry and technology,
then you're gonna be outdated and irrelevant
to the market place and that's gonna really
hurt your career.
And that's why I think blogging is really
important because it forces you to read because
the best bloggers are the best readers. The
more you understand what's going on, you can
more predictions, you can cite research, there's
so much more you can do with that content.
[pause]
And there's been a big branding shift; I think
people have to act more like companies, behave
more like companies. At the end of the day
success is in your hands, you have to be in
the driver's seat of your career not the passenger
seat.
And then companies have to act more like individuals
because consumers want to interact with companies.
I mean there was a report yesterday that said
56% of people on social networks are looking
for responses to their questions from companies.
So there's a huge demand for it, it's gonna
always increase, and so it's very important
that companies tap their employees to connect
in a human fashion with the outside world.
[pause]
And this is the Four Step Personal Branding
Process. Discover is about figuring out who
you are, how you want to brand yourself and
I always say for people who work in companies
becoming the go-to expert on a specific topic
or skill within your company so when people
need that skill or need some advice they go
to you each time and that's how you build
value.
Establishing short term and long term goals,
making sure both of those align as well.
Create is about creating the personal branding
toolkit like I mentioned earlier with all
the materials that you need to help sell you
whether you're a job seeker or employed or
you're an entrepreneur you always have to
keep those updated.
Communicate is what you have to do every single
day, really get out there, make sure people
are aware of your name, your face, and your
value. Seeing as though you have to be on
Twitter and Facebook and updating people,
so let them know what's going on with you
and your career.
And maintain is maintaining a positive image
for the rest of your life. It's not today
in fact it's something that you have to invest
in the long term.
[pause]
And this is the Success Triangle. The first
thing you need in order to be successful is
passion, you have to really love what you
do. You can't work for the weekend, you can't
wake up in the morning and just throw a brick
against the wall, it's just not gonna do much
for you. So if you really like what you do
you'll put in more effort, you'll make sacrifices
because if you really wanna get to a higher
level in your career there has to be come
sort of sacrifice that you have to make.
And then you have expertise. Expertise is
being able to fulfill job descriptions and
support other people and that's really how
you make money. But if you're an expert and
hate what you do or what you're an expert
in, you're not gonna be happy so you really
need both of those.
And the last piece is the support system,
this is the network component. You always
have to, you have to treat your life as a
networking event, you have to constantly meet
new people because that's how you're gonna
really advance.
And the thing about working for a company
is the more people you know early on, its
gonna support you guys to become a manager,
director, and beyond because once you're out
of that level it's not sustainable if you
don't have a network that can help you accomplish
your goals.
And then there's four other key words: authenticity,
some of these key words are buzz words, I'm
sure you've heard 'em a lot. Authenticity,
you have to be the real you, you don't wanna
copy anyone else, and your personality's your
greatest asset.
Transparency, you have to be up front and
honest with people. So when I got my new position
as a social media specialist back in 2007
I told them that I was gonna be speaking at
different places and everything I was doing
outside of work because if I didn't they could
just search for me online and find out the
hard way and that would affect my brand negatively.
Value, you have to figure out what your unique
value is, what your differentiation is, what
makes you different from the next person,
you need to answer these types of questions.
And then visibility, if people don't know
what you're doing, you don't exist to them.
If you're not found in search engines or social
networks it's gonna really hurt you.
[pause]
So there's four big brands here. We're gonna
go through each one and you're gonna say one
word that describes them. Michael Jackson?
>>[audience members respond]
>>Dan Schawbel: Anyone else?
Paris Hilton?
>>female #1: Rich.
>>Dan Schawbel: Obama?
Anyone?
>>[audience members respond]
>>Dan Schawbel: That's a good one. And Oprah?
>>Dan Schawbel: The reason why I just asked
you that is because I believe that if you
wanna manage your brand properly, your self
impression has to equal perceptions. So how
you describe yourself has to equal how people
describe you. And if you're doing that your
managing your brand correctly, right. So if
you think you're the smartest person in the
world and everyone thinks you're dumb, you
got an issue.
[pause]
And you wanna become an expert. This is, Edelman
puts this survey out every single year and
I got wind of it a few days ago and I'm thinking,
"Wow this is just so true." If you look at
from 2009 to 2011, experts and academics are
the most trusted. So just another reason why
you need to become an expert in your field
because people will trust you and that obviously
supports your company.
And you wanna take a niche. In general what
I believe is you have to brand yourself with
the career you want not the job you have because
if you position yourself online based on your
passion, what you're really, really interested
in, which might not be what you do at your
day job, you're gonna attract the right opportunities.
If you hate your job and you talk about how
much you hate your job online it's obviously
not good, but if you position yourself saying,
"I'm this type of engineer," online you're
gonna keep getting the opportunities that
you don't want. So it's almost like the law
of attraction online is if you put your real
self out there you're gonna attract the right
people, the right opportunities. If you don't
and you just copy someone else you're gonna
get the wrong opportunities. It really is
that simple.
And so the example that I share with you today
is how you can position yourself as an expert
and take a niche. So if you wanna become a
personal finance expert it's gonna be very
hard to compete with Suze Orman because she's
a well known brand, multi-time New York Times
bestseller, TV show, you name it. But if you
take a niche off of that and you say, "Hey
I live in Minnesota and I wanna become the
number one personal finance expert in this
area," then you can. And if you do that online,
you're gonna be found when someone searches
for you on Google and not Suze Orman. So you
have a chance at building a real business
and getting visibility. And people who live
in Minnesota, Suze Orman isn't a consultant
but they wouldn't pay for Suze Orman anyway
'cause they would wanna deal with someone
locally.
Here's another example: someone wants to become
known as the SEO expert in Utah. You Google
those terms, SEO, expert, Utah or SEO Utah,
he comes up first so he gets all of the visibility
and he gets all the opportunities.
And the final one is innovative legal counsel
for Gen Y entrepreneurs. This is a business
but look how focused that is: it's entrepreneurs
who are young. They could have just said innovative
legal counsel and then they're one of a billion
companies. But by segmenting your business
or segmenting yourself, you'll be very specific
and attract the right people that you can
serve and grow your business on.
[pause]
Creating a personal branding toolkit: so resume,
cover letter, link to profile, which I believe
is replacing cover letters and resumes. Video
resumes, which are popular but a lot of people
screw them up. So if you don't have the right
personality for it, don't do it it's gonna
hurt you. You know Tufts University, they
accept video resumes for their application
process so it's becoming more a possibility
familiar to these companies and to these academics.
Also the social networks: Facebook, LinkedIn,
Twitter are the main ones and we'll discuss
a little bit more about those; a blog versus
a website; website very static, blog more
dynamic.
And these are really just materials that you
can use: CD portfolio, or a website portfolio,
just to showcase what you can give to other
people. And the object of doing this is to
lower risk. So the more you put out there,
the more high quality things you put out there
the less risk a company has when thinking
of hiring you or not.
Blogging: so these are two blogs that we've
recently created for clients and the object
of creating a blog and what you need to do
now is you need to take a unique position,
you don't wanna recycle news, you need to
have your own opinions on them because that's
what's gonna attract other people and you
need to figure out what your voice is as well.
And then you have to make the investment.
You do need a custom website design now. If
you just steal someone else's templates not
gonna do much because there's 160 million
plus blogs; a lot of competition out there.
So if 100 blogs having the same template those
are probably going to be ignored, but the
ones who invest in their blog or their website,
those are the ones that are gonna capture
more attention.
And then social networking's great, Google+
one button, Facebook share button all that
has to be in all blog posts and on your sites
because people are finding out about new content
on blogs and traditional media sites though
social networks first. So if you don't enable
your community to share your content quickly,
you're gonna miss out on building that type
of community that you're looking to get.
And then upkeep: you have to be committed
to anything that you really care about and
if you have a blog you have to be really committed
to it. You can't just update it once every
six months; it's gonna make you look bad because
everything is dated. So the reason why you
go to Facebook all the time is because you
don't want it to say last update 2009, like
where is this person? If I drop off for 72
hours people think I'm dead and that this
is the world we're living on, a lot of people
live online.
[pause]
The big three social networks, I don't know
if you can see this, together they have over
a billion users I mean people are on the same
ones, but huge users bases. The number one
question I always get asked is what do I do
with my Facebook profile, employers are looking
at it and search my name on Facebook and I
don't want them to see my conversations that
I have with family and friends. So keep 'em
private, keep everything private as much as
you can. Of course people can get their hands
on information if they want to or if they
wanna spend money, but you need to protect
yourself as much as possible and maybe establish
a fan page, you can use that as your professional
identity.
And then Twitter is great because you can
connect on the same, how many of you are on
Twitter?
[pause]
Twitter's great because you're all in the
same place and you can network and have access,
access if one of the key words, to people
that you wouldn't have access to before. Because
you can go in and you can form a relationship
with experts in your industry, hiring managers,
directors, entrepreneurs, whoever you want.
And if you specifically target these individuals
you can form relationships in a public setting.
The way I look at this, the way I look at
Twitter is, that instead of asking a girl
or guy over to your place the first night,
first time you see them, you're establishing,
you're putting the other person in a very
comfortable situation because it's like taking
them to the movies or to dinner. That's how
I look at it.
And then LinkedIn: LinkedIn's valuable especially
if you already have a strong network because
you just import all your contacts and then
you use those contacts to tap into the second
or third degree relationships. So it gives
you access through a referral based system
which is more powerful than just sending someone
a blind resume or a blind email to other people
that can help you in your career.
[pause]
We're on to communicate.
There's so many different ways you can promote
yourself now as simple as an email signature
with a URL, a blog URL, a website URL, social
network profile, LinkedIn profile. There's
also writing a book or an eBook, starting
a blog, going to charity events --
[pause]
becoming a member of an association, becoming
a leader in the association, speaking, attending
networking events. There's so many different
ways: being active on blogs, commenting, and
going to forums and commenting. You just have
to get out there and it takes a lot of work.
If you build a website or blog, people aren't
just gonna come because there's so many. So
you have to be in the driver's seat again
and you have to go get those users by playing
where they are, right, fishing where they
are, fishing where the fish are.
Networking now exists on three levels. When
I grew up, my parents said, "It's all about
who you know." But with LinkedIn and other
social networks and the social graph on top
of them, it's now about who they know and
that information for the first time ever is
available to you. You can see through your
network who knows who and tap into those contacts.
Before, I'd say seven to ten years ago, you're
not gonna go ask all your friends, "Oh, who
do you know? Do you know him that knows her?"
I mean it's just not gonna work like that.
So LinkedIn's a little more regulated where
you can see okay I know you work at this company
but look one of your contacts works at a company
that I wanna work for as well, and then you
can just tap into that so there's a lot, a
lot of that in there.
And the last piece is it's who knows you and
this is what happens when you start to build
a brand, become more well known is more people
know you than you know people. And when people
know you, you've probably created some degree
of word of mouth so they can say nice things
about you. And what other people say about
your brand is more impactful than what you
say about yourself especially if they're respected
by society. If the New York Times says your
grade, it counts for a lot more than if you
say your grade to other people. If your manager
says or a VP tells your manager you're doing
a great job, it counts a lot more than if
you tell your manager that you're doing a
good job.
[pause]
And we're really entering a world of one-on-one
marketing. I think it's becoming more obvious
everyday because Tweets and Facebook updates
are being ignored 'cause there's so many of
'em. People are following hundreds, the average
person in the UK on Facebook has at least
a thousand friends. So it's so much content,
so many people and a lot of that content's
being ignored. The best thing you can do is
focus in on the right people that you want
to form relationships with and spend more
of your time with those people rather than
trying to mass market yourself which is very
ineffective.
[pause]
Four rules of brand relationships that I live
by. The first one is mutualism; it's creating
win-win situations in business. The other
person has to get as much out of the deal
as you do and if they don't it's not gonna
be a long term relationship.
The next one is giving which is the number
one most important networking rule.
>>female #1: Could you give some example of
that first one.
>>Dan Schawbel: Yeah, so if you're in a business
deal,
>>female #1: Um-hum.
>>Dan Schawbel: and you let's say create someone's
website,
>>female #1: Um-hum.
>>Dan Schawbel: and they give you $10,000
and the website's really not at the level
it should be at --
[pause]
you're getting more than they're getting.
>>female #1: Right.
>>Dan Schawbel: It's all about, it's really
about value.
>>female #1: But I guess maybe like with some
financial transactions because you were talking
about branding or are you just talking about
financial transactions?
>>Dan Schawbel: Well I'm mean financial transactions
is one of them, but it goes with anything.
If you're selling something to somebody and
they feel like they're getting ripped off
it's not gonna be a long term relationship,
and that's why it kind of goes back to giving,
helping out other people without asking for
anything in return. Because then people are
more apt to help you it's just naturally how
it works.
And then reconnecting is another really important
rule. You need to constantly reconnect with
people that you really care about because
if they go under the radar for four years,
it's not gonna be a long term relationship.
But if you contact them maybe six times a
year at least then it means, it shows that
you care and they'll probably help you in
some way if you ever need it. It's like if
you get a Facebook friend request or message
from someone you hated in high school, you're
still not gonna help them, but if you liked
someone in high school and they kept in contact
with you, you might help them. It's a big
difference.
And then the last one is targeting. So it's
again like I said a few times, being very
specific with the people you wanna go after,
not trying to mass market or mass network
yourself, knowing the type of people in your
industry that interest you and then focusing
your attention on those. You'll get a lot
more out of it. It's like if you go to a networking
event, instead of passing out 500 business
cards --
[pause]
taking five business cards, meeting the five
people you really, really are interested in
and spending the entire time with them.
[pause]
And maintain: what does Google say about you?
That's a plug for you. [chuckles] So what
I'm gonna ask you now is how many people do
you think Google themselves, what percentage
of people Google themselves? Just shout out
any number.
[pause]
>>male #1: Thirty.
>>Dan Schawbel: Thirty. It's actually 57%
of people self Google and 53% of people Google
others. And I think these are actually low,
I think it's just becoming more of a habit
for people right now.
[pause]
And reputation management 2.0 because I believe
Google's your permanent record. When people
search for you it can have a negative or a
positive impact on your career based on what
shows up. Anthony Weiner, from the House of
Representatives, he had a huge issue because
he didn't understand that the Web was such
a public place and it came back to bite him
of course. So if you look at what happened
to him, he's Tweeting and putting up all these
pictures, it's becoming public and even if
one person saw it and he takes it down, that
one person can do a print screen and paste
it and share it and can reblog it and can
share it with someone else and they can put
video on it. So one mistake can actually go
viral now and really hurt someone's brand.
And I'm not sure if he's gonna retire or anything
or step down, but if you Google his name,
it's all negative. And if you go to his Wikipedia
it has this incident on it.
And a new survey came out by Retrevo that
said 35% of people post something that they
later regret. What you post right now could
affect you 35 years from now, because it's
always gonna visible whether it's on the 2nd
page or the 50th page. Someone's trying to
research your background and see if they wanna
hire you and work with you, that's where they're
turning to.
[pause]
And you can actually be proactive and set
up a great defense to combat anything negative
that would occur in the future. So Google
Profile, Facebook, professional page where
you have facebook.com/your full name. LinkedIn
getting a URL in LinkedIn; registering on
Twitter. Again use your name, your picture,
and position all these profiles and websites
and blogs the same way. And everything if
you link everything together they'll reinforce
one another and they'll all start to rank
higher. And it's great to preserve all this
before someone else does so you have a little
bit more control and because they rank high
for name especially if you have a unique name,
that can combat something that would have
happen in the future that would be a threat
to you in your career.
And what you need to do is you need to monitor
your name to see what people are saying about
you. You need to monitor different key words
that pertain to your industry and your profession.
You need to monitor what people are saying
about your company, any partners and competitors.
And you can set all this up by going to google.com/alerts
which you're probably familiar with and setting
comprehensive alert for your name, business,
and etcetera.
And then backtype.com does the same for blog
comments, then boardtracker.com does the same
for forums online, and then you have Social
Mention which searches your name on many different
networks and microblogs. You have this Technorati
which can search one of the most authoritative
blogs. You have Facebook, Facebook you can
do a search through your contacts and then
you can do a search through everyone on Facebook
for your name and what people are saying about
you. And then Twitter you can go to search.twitter.com
or tweetbeep.com and set an alert for your
name and you pull that all into a google.com/reader
so you can follow what people are saying about
you and do something about it before it's
a forest fire and negative viral activity
on your name.
[pause]
And what ends up happening is you collect
all this information about what people are
saying about you and your company and key
buzz words and all this information you care
about along with all the articles that you
subscribe to and all the blogs you subscribe,
and pull all that into Google Reader and then
you take the best of that content, you organize
it, use in delicious.com and then you distribute
it using maybe a presentation or a blog or
social network profiles or maybe you cite
something in your blog. And this is a great
system to have because it's very easy to use
and if you get into the right rhythm you can
make things happen very quick and stay updated.
And you have to get your voice online as much
as possible so people remember you and you
become top of minds so when they're looking
to hire someone or work with someone they
think of you first. But if they don't see
your face for a few weeks you're out of sight
out of mind.
[pause]
And the reputation marketplace it's at cloud.com.
How many, raise your hand if you're familiar
with cloud.com. Anyone?
[pause]
So cloud.com is basically is it basically
gives you a reputation metric of how influential
you are online. So it now takes into account
LinkedIn so it has LinkedIn, Twitter, and
Facebook. So based on the amount of people
who follow you, who those people are, how
many people are retweeting and sharing your
content, you're gonna get a score from zero
to one hundred. And then people with the highest
scores for different topics get rewarded different
prizes, they call it perks.
And to me this is becoming more and more important
because employers are actually using this
when hiring now. And that's a huge shift and
this number the more accurate it gets the
more weight it's gonna carry in recruitment
process so it's definitely something to pay
attention to.
And you can bring more value to your company
using social networking sites. So recruitment,
PR, marketing, you name it. Bloggers have
been known to sell products that their company
sell on their blogs and it works over 60%
of the time they've been able to do that.
Free marketing, your company messages, your
company press releases, any big announcements,
you can promote all that through networks
and seen as a value add to your company.
Public relations we have negative things happen
online, people are saying bad things about
your company, get right in there, putting
the facts into play, help people out, you
can prevent the negative viral activity.
Recruitment: having your networks to source
the right people. You're probably already
connected to people who would be a good fit
for Google and that really helps your company,
too.
So really at the end of the day it's about
bringing more value to your current job, putting
in the extra effort, staying later, doing
that whatever it will take in order to get
to that next level in your career depending
on what you're looking ahead.
And you need to command your future, you need
to be careful about what you put online because
it could come back to haunt you it could really
screw things up for you when you get older.
You have to really love what you do, passion's
the only thing that's sustainable so if you
hate what you do it's gonna be very hard for
you to be successful at doing that.
You have to form relationships that's what
all this is about; the more people you know
the more people who are connected to you and
care what you have to say, the better. And
you also wanna be talking you wanna be trying
yourself again.
And you gotta work hard. Go back to what I
said before a lot of the stuff I discussed
today takes a little bit more time than what
you would normally do at a day job, but it's
gonna help you and it's gonna safeguard your
career and allow you to advance in the future,
it's an investment in yourself.
So I want to thank you today. My book Me 2.0
all of you have it in front of you and personalbrandingblog.com
has over 2,000 articles on personal branding
and we have a newsletter, too, that goes out
monthly if you wanna subscribe to that.
And I appreciate your time. If you have any
questions feel free to ask it now. If you
have a question later you can always email
me at dan@millennialbranding.com.
Appreciate it.
[applause]